Esta es una historia de dos carruajes
reales uno de ellos moderno con aire
acondicionado y amortiguadores que será
utilizado para llevar a Carlos y Camila
a la Bahía de Westminster un viaje de
ensueño según funcionarios y que no era
realizado desde el jubileo de diamante
en 2014 el interior está bellamente
tapizado en seda encajado en el interior
y tiene muestras de Maderas exclusivas
es un verdadero ejemplo de la historia
británica y mundial hay maderas de las
residencias reales de las exploraciones
y de otros países es un guiño a la
historia el segundo carruaje tiene una
larga historia será el encargado de
regresar al palacio de buckingham a la
pareja recién coronada fue construido
hace 261 años y usado para la coronación
de la difunta Reina Isabel en 1953 quien
aseguraba que era terriblemente incómodo
incluso William IV en 1831 dijo que su
coronación fue como estar Atrapado en un
barco en un mar embravecido es el
segundo coche de trabajo más antiguo
país fue construido en 1762 lo que lo
convierte en un coche de trabajo
increíblemente antiguo en el mundo son
muy pocas las monarquías que han
mantenido coches de esta edad trabajando
por lo tanto es algo increíblemente
especial para ver un hombre será el
encargado de controlar los ocho caballos
que jalen el carruaje y de mantener
cómodos a Los Monarcas
debido a los caballos tienes que
mantenerte tranquilo y demostrar el
control para transmitirle a los caballos
que estamos bien la ruta para la
coronación también ha sido revelada
Carlos y Camila viajarán desde el
Palacio de buckingham pasando miles de
ovaciones girarán y luego se dirigirán
hacia la abadía de Westminster 2000
limitados estarán allí millones más
verán la cobertura en vivo y admirarán
la capacidad de la pareja para mantener
las tradiciones reales en su incómodo
viaje de regreso